Jeff Goldblum film star but you're not
here tonight as film star you here as a
musician Jeff Jeff Gould who is our
music act tonight explain the Rings yes
I do
why what why what do you think about
that off you play piano of course yes I
would prefer to take off the Rings but I
like I like to look that this summer
this is an extraordinary honor the
statue of you was unveiled no I did not
write in fact I didn't know that was
going up I learned the first day that
was up say 7:00 say hey look what's up
in the and I went Wow well things we
thought oh how lovely we could wear you
know bring the statue here and showed
you I was like we hadn't quite
understood the scale of this I read what
it was it's like 25 feet long and so etc
10 so all I can offer you all right if
you're allowed to keep this I heard
about this I've not seen it this
this
is Jess ovens hey hey
excuse my excuse my buttocks really look
at that thing oh my golly hey Jeff you
can post it on Facebook is the lowest
form of humor true or false let's see
Wow well I thought that would be I
thought it was made of its like
papier-mache I thought it would be
concrete of some kind though you can
take that home
well I'm not sure we can give it to you
I'll be giving a job no no no somebody
wants your back I don't know what I do
it didn't I I didn't realize it could be
decapitated but I then I think when they
told me it was sectional you know
imagine if this were like a voodoo doll
I would have felt something but you know
ah there you go like a Wolverine yes I
was kind of like a little green thing
gun yeah let's just lay you here thank
that's just gonna be big head yeah there
you go
[Applause]
[Music]
you